he's got his new program coming out on
hbo we've been talking about it with him
for quite some time uh he is joining us
here on the rich eisen show as game
theory with bomani jones is right around
the corner it starts streaming on march
the 13th
new series on hbo and hbo max bomani
jones how are you bomani
i want to start this with one of my
favorite quotes from music that after
you guys brought this person up i have
to read okay this is a quote from miles
davis
i remember one time it might have been a
couple of times that the fillmore east
in 1970 i was opening for this sorry ass
cat named steve miller steve miller
didn't have fleet going for him so i'm
pissed because i got to open for this
non-playing mf just because he had one
or two sorry ass records out so i would
come late and he would have to go on
first and then we got out there we
smoked the mf plate everybody dug it
that is from miles dave's autobiography
[Applause]
do you have his autobiography just
around you or you just you literally
have that committed to memory what was
that i i pulled it up on the computer
after you mentioned him but
anytime i hear steve miller now that is
my immediate thought is why did miles
davis do that deal with that
autobiography i love it
fantastic uh congrats in advance of the
debut march 13th debut of your show
bomani you will have nothing short of
everything to talk about it seems like
on that program to kick off yeah nah
like one thing is interesting is that
we'll be doing like some big picture
stuff we'll also be getting into like
the topical um elements of what's going
on out here but you're right we picked a
good week to come out here because the
football world is caught on fire and
that whole britney griner thing is its
own amazing situation yeah we got it
baseball which somehow could be more
interesting by not playing
yep i mean so there's so much to discuss
and uh game theory with bomani jones
again on hbo premieres on uh march 13th
so uh let's get right into it what did
you think about the trade between
seattle and uh and denver what do you
think about russ now winding up in
denver your two cents on that subject
so you know when
detroit traded stafford to los angeles
it was very much a feeling
of good for the lions right like this
guy doesn't want to be there anymore
it's been hard enough let's just go
ahead and send them somewhere nice and
that's what they did
with russell in seattle it just seemed
like everybody was tired of everybody
because i would have thought that they
could have gotten more of a package for
him than the one that they ultimately
got back and the one they got back
wasn't bad but you compare it like the
staffer package i'm not sure that it's
the same and i think most of us would
have said that we thought that russell
wilson was a better quarterback than
matthew stafford but see what i wanted
to hear for the broncos just because so
many people stay good really old doesn't
mean that everybody's going to do that
and so russell wilson is 33 years old
he's taking 40 45 sacks a year since he
got into the league 10 years ago
i don't know for how much longer he's
going to be a guy that you can expect to
play elite level quarterback
so you would not have taken that shot
that denver took
well i think if i'm denver i take the
shot because it's the best chance that
you're going to have like everybody gets
it gets a bit handcuffed when you're in
a year where there's no good quarterback
in the draft right where there's nobody
in the draft that anybody seems to have
real enthusiasm about so then it's like
well where do you go to find a
quarterback
good quarterbacks are typically not
available like i would even if i'm on
the phone with seattle why this happened
given that seattle is still trying to do
something to win now i'm really
skeptical as to why it is this thing is
for sale but just because he wants to be
traded what that got to do with anything
well i mean that's the ultimate mystery
bomani um and that one i still can't get
a straight
answer about even even privately um
people if you will close to the
situation
do not talk about it's like fight club
or third rail whatever you want to say
is
why did russell wilson have to go why
did he want to go why did this marriage
get dissolved what happened
here
i don't get it well
you know the front office doesn't seem
to like him very much like he he doesn't
seem to elicit the warm and fuzzies from
the people who around him and the things
that we heard about the way richard
sherman and those guys looked at him it
doesn't sound like those guys
necessarily liked him that's not to say
that he's a bad leader because he might
have been good at leading them but he
doesn't one thing about russell wilson
if you've ever talked to him and i i
imagine you guys have had the pleasure
of him not answering your questions on
your radio show like i've had the
pleasure of him not answering my
questions on my radio show and when he
doesn't answer your questions on a radio
show it's not like he tries to be slick
about it like he'll laugh to acknowledge
wow what a great question that i would
answer if i wasn't russell wilson and
then he just starts talking about
something else like i don't know how
many people in his actual life like
really know that dude because anytime we
wind up around him when we see him he's
giving a projection of what russell
wilson quarterback is supposed to be and
i don't know how well that works when
you're actually dealing with people
every day like especially with the type
of personalities they used to have on
that team the kind of personality that
pete carroll is but i am floored that a
team that still thinks it has a chance
to win now whether that's true or not is
his own discussion but if they think
they have a chance to win now and they
traded a hall of fame quarterback away
wow
or they just figured that they didn't
have a chance to win right now and that
without a first round selection this
year
this is their best chance to reset
and better to do it now
than try and run back what they did last
year that may be it too bomani you know
yeah it could and i want to see what
quarterback they ultimately wind up with
because that's when russell wilson's
going to get really mad about this like
if he looks up and they think fine we'll
just go get jimmy garoppolo oh man i'll
be ready to fire something down like
what exactly is it that you're trying to
say about me
and so i just don't know what option
there is for them to land like i am
actually talking myself into the idea
that mr trubisky is going to be a good
option for somebody i'm really getting
to that point i don't feel great about
it but i got an argument but if they
ain't gonna win nothing if they got mr
trubisky
bomani jones here on the rich eisen show
uh about five minutes before you joined
um carson wentz was acquired by the
washington commanders he's back in the
nfc east he's now a twice traded
quarterback
um who had a season last year that put
the colts in position to be
kind of like the niners that proverbial
team you didn't want to see but then
they fell flat he got coveted he wasn't
vaccinated he got covered um
at a time when it appeared it didn't
really matter if you were vaxxed or not
but i just bring that up because that is
something that's stuck in the craw of
the colts um and it's stuck in the craw
of the cowboys with the ma uh you know
amari cooper putting it all together
though that's my long wind up by saying
uh wence to me doesn't appear to be that
big swing quarterback that washington
commander fans were hopeful for i wonder
what your thought is on that subject
i'm just amazed that people keep talking
himself into him
like that year that he had
the the year before last the 2020 season
was an all-time terrible year for a
quarterback
very few quarterbacks ever get a chance
to start again after playing that poorly
let alone somebody trade a first round
pick to get you then somebody else after
you don't come through when it matters
at the end of that season still talking
yourselves into this 29 year old
quarterback that doesn't even
necessarily um relate that well to
people and whose team didn't necessarily
like him that much when he was in
philadelphia and that's that's what's so
wild to me about this is i understand
that there's a quarterback scarcity but
why do you think that this guy is
something different than what he's
demonstrated himself to be and so let's
say he's in the same camp as garoppolo
which is something that you could make
an argument for after the way it ended
last year like i heard you right before
i came on and you were saying with him
he was good until he wasn't and there's
some guys jimmy garoppolo her cousin
carson wentz there's always going to be
until he wasn't that moment is always
going to come up do you want a
quarterback where you know in the end
he's going to be the one to mess it up
um
what about the rogers re-signing what do
you think now that we've and it's
amazing
his re-signing bomani jones uh was front
page news if you will
uh top of the uh
uh new stack news uh top of our twitter
feed news for about 90 minutes until the
the um wilson trade came in and we've
been waiting two years to find out how
roger's long-term
uh future would be decided for green bay
we finally have it he's staying put
the one thing i want to give aaron
rodgers credit for and he's done a lot
of kooky things in the course of the
past few months but i appreciated the
fact that when it wasn't going well with
the packers and he said it wasn't going
well when it got better he acknowledged
that it was getting better and gave
credit to everybody for actually putting
in work for it to get better like i
actually think that for all the things
that there's room to slam aaron rodgers
for
the way that he handled his relationship
with the packers and his ultimate
resolution actually made him look pretty
good in the situation because he could
have caught him after a donkey when he
showed up this year to make sure that he
got out and he said they made it work
now the counterpoint on this i can't
remember if i've given this high take on
this show it's a bit theoretical but i
think it has to be all right you have
the floor
if you play your home games in a stadium
that is an icebox in january i'm not
sure a pass heavy approach is the
smartest way to play right like you
remember in baseball in the 80s when
bush stadium in st louis was like 414 to
deep center and it was a cavern and so
they did finally just got a bunch of
dudes slap the ball around on astroturf
and run really fast because you were
never going to win there playing like
trying to get a bunch of home runs and i
feel like the passing revolution in the
nfl makes a lot of sense in the regular
season and then you forget that games
are played outdoors in january in a lot
of places and so i've always wondered
with with him and even to a degree brett
favre as it went on with him in his
career is there a home field
disadvantage to building everything
around the quarterback if you're going
to play in green bay everybody else
that plays that far north got a dome
like half your division guy domes except
for you old-timey teams that think
there's something cool about playing in
frostbite
well i i i have heard this before not
from you though so i'll just respond by
saying i totally get it
and i understand it and i would agree
with it as a
uh an indication of
the future
possibilities and successes of aaron
rodgers
if not for the fact that aj dylan was a
was drafted and he's the he's the guy
that you're supposed to roll
down the frozen tundra lane to knock the
the pins out of your opponent in in a
playoff game like this one against san
francisco and he got hurt so it's not
like he was there and they went away or
rogers audibled out of it
they had the guy and they had it set up
but the
once again we're left wondering the why
and what happened
with rogers
leading a team you know like so i
totally understand it um i guess i need
to see it run back one more time before
i can say
you've you've you've hit the nail
directly on the head but you're
definitely around and i will say this
yeah if you got the option you go with
aaron rodgers you know what i mean like
it's like if this is the play you make
and honestly special teams is what did
it mean this time and you know no matter
what kind of leader we think aaron
rodgers is we don't expect him to lead
special teams too like he'll pay him
that much money um and so i mean he's
definitely the play and that offense is
definitely built for them to run the
ball if they need to but i think that
all these teams don't need to really
reconsider when this gets late man
there's a reason why you just pound
teams it still works i swear it does
bomani jones here on the rich eisen show
so uh what uh what do you want folks to
know about
game theory what's it gonna look like
who's your first guest walk me through
the rundown
for the show man i keep i keep
forgetting to ask people if i'm allowed
to say the particulars of it because i
think they're gonna release it so i can
tell you this i can't tell you who the
first guest is but i can tell you it is
legitimately one of the biggest names in
sports and not an athlete but one of the
biggest names in sports and we are
premiering on selection sunday and we
are going to do a fantastic piece that
is commemorating a very important figure
in the history of college basketball and
i say to watch this because this show is
really going to be fun like i'm in a
situation where they really gave me the
keys and said we're going to put
together the show that you want so like
if you've seen me on television in the
last however many years through no fault
of anybody else's but by and large it's
me on a show that's built to exist
outside of me this is me on a show that
is built absolutely for me like we got a
great team of writers we got a great
team of producers and this is the most
creative thing that i have ever done
like i've spent the better part of
however many months just kind of sitting
around and coming up with stuff and
figuring out like so if i was doing a
podcast segment about this now we can
take it to the next level because we got
a field team that can go out and shoot
something that surrounded that and i got
other really smart brilliant people that
can look at what i said and be like hey
well what about this well maybe we can
add that and everything else so like
stuff i've done before was probably
limited by my brain now we're expanding
outside of all of that and we did a test
show a couple weeks ago and the biggest
compliment that we got from the
executives really was
this feels like a show that's supposed
to be on hbo well then congratulations i
don't know how good
i say this i don't know how good episode
two gonna be but i can tell you episode
one gonna be a smoker well uh
i love it bomani and and i say
congratulations in advance without even
seeing it because way back in the day
one of uh a few agents ago uh
one of my agents said to me at the time
what do you want out of your career like
what what what is exactly you want out
of your career and i thought it was a
trick question and he's like the one
thing that you can have out of your
career is what
and you know i say longevity money you
know whatever and you know
i said finally uncle what is it and he
said the ability to choose your own
assignments because everything else
comes from that
and for you to be able to be set up the
way that you are set up on hbo is
terrific i mean that's a rarity in our
business
and um you know uh
one of the producers adam mckay i mean
he couldn't be more
smart and successful and you know
obviously big time so in advance i say
congrats and i can't wait to see what
you're cooking up
look man i appreciate it mina kyles was
kind enough to send me a picture they
had put an advertisement up for this
show at beverly cena like oh okay that's
what we're doing like every now and then
there's a moment where i'm like oh this
is legit we sat down for the test show
and it's like and action and the
from hbo came up and i wasn't expecting
that at all
like i was like oh snap
you got to stop down huh i would i don't
blame you that's pretty cool bomani that
is great uh so when the six uh episode
run ends on april 17th what lakers team
will be uh taking the floor around then
do you think
man like who's still gonna want to feel
like doing this like one of the worst
things with them in this situation is
that russell westbrook is a man of
character and when i say that i mean
they would probably love to like send
him home but that man is not the man
that's going to go and let you like to
steal paychecks that's not him he's one
of my favorite players ever because
nobody goes as hard as him but i've
always said part of why he's one of my
favorite players is i've never rooted
for his team like the consequences and
results of his play have never mattered
to me i just appreciate the ethos that's
behind it but they
they have such problems because it goes
so far beyond russell westbrook because
the truth of the matter is you shouldn't
make your player
the man in charge of the whole operation
and i just think they've given lebron
too much power and the team they have is
one that i don't think can win a
championship and i don't think you get
better and so what was a poorly run
organization is now a poorly run
organization that seems to be one
faction being the star player in his
agency that represents six players on
the team and on the other side all the
people who have been there forever and
kind of resent it
so
uh boiling it all down uh getting set to
be the away team in their own arena in a
play-in game is that basically what
you're saying right now can you think
that i can't think of anything more
embarrassing than if the lakers were to
lose a play-in game to the clippers
without paul george and without kawhi
leonard at their old house to miss the
entire playoffs like i just experienced
the exhilarating joy of duke losing
coach k's last game against carolina at
home couldn't have been better couldn't
have been better this is like the only
thing i can imagine being like halfway
close to it but for a different reason
not because it's a rivalry but the idea
that the lakers is embarrassing enough
that you've got to play in this
contrivance just to get in and you might
lose at your own house to the clippers
that would be the debut of the sequel
firing time on hbo right
[Laughter]
yeah pray vogue is just got to be like
look man i i don't know what else i can
do
nobody thinks this is his fault
everybody thinks he should be fired
that's what a guaranteed contract does
that is a perfect way to say it
everybody thinks it's not his fault but
everybody thinks that she should still
be fired at his unfortunate spot to be
in
as an hc anywhere
nobody guaranteed though i wish somebody
would fire me for guaranteed money
yeah so once the uh before we let bomani
jones go go ahead and hit him yeah both
uh we're the same age tj here we're big
music fans as you know it's the 25th
anniversary today of the notorious big's
death if you just could just speak on
his cultural significance still to this
day maybe what's your favorite song
favorite lyric etc
i know it's probably really important to
you
yeah i think the biggest thing that i'll
always remember is that morning that i
found out i can't remember that was the
9th of the 10th but i was on the way to
work i was busting tables at five rugs
at willow brook mall and the news came
over that big ear died
and i was 16 but i remember man that was
that hit me really hard but part of why
it hit me really hard was this is like
six months after two pocket died and it
all felt like a fade to calm plea in a
way that was just hurtful right and it
just felt like like everything just felt
like such chaos because this dude was
the coldest like in terms of just the
ability to manipulate words and make
sounds out of it and everything else he
was so
good and managed to become like
supremely famous largely on the strength
of just being so good but if you want
best lyrics they're probably all in
victory the first verse of victory is
like one of the most amazing pieces of
writing that anybody has ever done and
also i'm kind of doing it like this
because most of my favorite figgy lines
are not appropriate for the federal
commission
that's the tv what the uh the tv mature
17 rating that you're gonna see on hbo
maybe i got you hey congrats again on
your show uh let's let's do this again
uh very soon i always enjoy when you
call in and have a and have a chat
terrific thank you thanks so much thank
you so much man i'll talk to you soon
you got it march 13th on hbo streaming
on hbo max game theory with bomani jones
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here